A critical thing we need to keep in mind when building network games is detecting the environment
that we're running in. For that we have the net modes enum. Frankly, the net mode is the
most watertight way of querying whether or not the current environment is a client
or a server one, a fact that often impacts our implementations. Let's take a look at
what net modes come with Unreal and where we might use them. First up we have the
standalone net mode. This executable is running in total isolation and is in no way
subject to a server's authority. We can pretty much surmise that we're running a
single-player game at this point. The dedicated server net mode however is exactly as you'd
expect. It's a dedicated server with no local controllers, only connecting
clients. The listen server net mode is a bit of a blend. This executable is acting
as both client and a server. Other controllers are connecting to this
client with this local client being the host. The client net mode is the
opposite of the dedicated server as you'd expect. This executable is connecting to a
remote authoritative server. Net mode checks often come into play when building
out features that have both front and back ends. So let's take a health
component for instance. We'd want to check that we're currently under the
dedicated server net mode when actually applying damage, but we'd want to check
if we're under the client net mode when playing any on-screen effects or
updating any UI elements. A net mode check is the safest way of checking
you're currently under the appropriate environment. Although thematically
similar to net mode, net role deals more specifically with the authority of the
given circumstance. It won't directly tell us if we're on a server or not but
it will let us know if the current environment is authoritative or an actor.
When we call get local role on an actor we return one of three roles.
Authority lets us know that this actor was spawned locally, this environment
spawned it and can refer to both clients and servers. Should we change
anything about this actor under the authority role we know that A, a server
isn't going to correct it back to another value and B, if we're currently
on a server and this actor is replicated the change may be propagated
down through replication. It really is critical to note that authority
absolutely does not mean server. It expressly means that the actor in
question was spawned locally and is seen as the single source of truth in
regards to how this actor is altered. Case in point, a client responding to
damage locally by spawning VFX would be spawning authoritative particle
systems. Simulated proxy however means the actor was spawned on the server
and replicated down to the local client. It's owned by another client
but requires representation locally. A perfect example of this would be
another player in your world. Some other client owns it but the server
is still authoritative. It has been sent to the local machine because it
requires some kind of representation. Conversely autonomous proxy is the
other side of the coin. The actor was spawned on the server but the
local machine owns it so that would be your player character in this context.